ça c'est moi
sami benboudaoud
il ya dix ans j'ai rencontré pour la
première fois mon charmant cousin
charles des chazelles ma chambre tu les
aimes ou tu la quittes à nice où sarko
la vie était plutôt douces et les choses
ont pas mal changé depuis que ma famille
n'a pas du tout digéré la défaite de
sarkozy
enfin surtout charles d'un cancer du
cerveau
non c'est une sarkozyte aiguë mon oncle
et son ex-femme s'entendent toujours
aussi bien crevure pas de mère la [ __ ]
peux dire que mon oncle a eu quelques
petits soucis avec la justice avez vous
un compte au panama du coup ils ont tous
débarqué chez moi
dans ma cité à nanterre voilà voilà
bienvenue chez toi
voici le stade qu ils ont eu comme un
petit choc tant famille est ici bien
gucci chapop c'est bon pour ce que ta
[ __ ] surtout charles ont cette fois
fait des coups de mer mais ta part de
mes clients me crie quoi allez-vous
samara coucher mon amour avec des gains
pour sa main non mais on est où là c'est
quoi ça écoute moi bien panoramix les
tomes ont besoin c'est pas un looser il
a repris sa vie en main
ben voilà c'est fini la guerre du feu
bon bah la bonne nouvelle c'est que tu
vas mieux tu présentais la mairie de
nanterre la mauvaise c'est que t'as pas
changé comment je fais pour faire plus
local ou qui déboule chez nous comme ça
avec la famille la vie de la chamade
chez l'homme smash à la charia c'est la
route à la metula pas
avantage quand on a touché le fond des
comptes au coeur montée
à toi pour gagner cousin et moi je veux
tu perds comme une grosse merde je serai
en quelque sorte un peu votre mac rond
mais de gauche
[Musique]